oh my god you know what yeah there's two
white people in one black guy in the
woods I'm not sure I'm Becky hey I'm
destiny I'm cute I'm Jackie
and today we're gonna
[Music]
my parents were military so I you yeah I
used to take MREs on like sporting
events my parents weren't around
oh I haven't prepared I've had
freeze-dried ice cream and it kind of
just tastes like sweet styrofoam I've
never had freeze-dried food but I've
definitely had some freezer-burnt
we're both great for this repair you
would think I would because I'm
terrified of disasters and I have a lot
of anxiety about them but it doesn't
seem to equal being in any way prepared
for them I do I actually have a really
small kit I've been meaning to refurbish
it it's basically I have a lot of water
and I have a little little kit that has
like bandages I don't have an emergency
kit I remember the first time I moved to
LA it was with my school and they gave
us an earthquake ready kit that
apparently is like $500 a bucket I've
never been prepared for like a disaster
and I don't have anything for disaster
prep I do have a bottled water one
bottle water and I have a several but I
just like to drink water all right I'm
ready for the end of the world let's go
damn this looks
oh no it's warm oh this is hot oh okay
hold on ha ha ha ha ha
I have the breakfast skillet and was in
there it's got some hashbrowns scrambled
eggs mixed with pork sausage patty
pepper and onions
I have freeze-dried precooked scrambled
eggs with ham kept ham and peppers this
looks really good I have chili magma
beef and it has spicy sauce with
macaroni beef and beans I have chicken
fried rice with vegetables that sounds
good and honestly it smells nice looks
nice
can I eat it oh my god you know what
yeah there's two white people in one
black guy in the woods I'm
sure well I have to eat it that's what I
am here for huh
I'll bring them you didn't try this one
this wouldn't be comforting in a bad
situation no I will starve I wasn't sure
what was gonna go down in this video I
was actually kind of upset but now we
here I'm happy this is my this is good
yeah oh yeah
try this one okay we're switching it up
yeah yeah yeah yeah ah it tastes almost
like you can taste that it was powdered
first and then made into something maybe
they do that on purpose so they can make
sure that you pace yourself that's
pretty good right yeah
chilly they both just tastes like cheap
like food oh right I know
oh my god the texture is bad - smells
bad - flavors endearing about this there
are many situations in which an
emergency prepared kit to be necessary
including but not limited to wildfires
oh god this is gonna give me such
anxiety hurricanes tornadoes terrorist
attacks floods and earthquakes ready.gov
has recommendations and tips for many of
these emergency situations and others
even like biological and chemical attack
cyber incidents droughts landslides home
fires snowstorms and escape weather
preparing for natural disasters is
important to decrease your risks and in
an uncertain climate for safety and
hygiene if I'm ever caught in a tornado
I want my last meal literally in the
tornado yeah oh no no I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna wait until I'm out of the
tornado
I didn't think and I realized right now
how many ways I can die just imagine
somebody did a cyberattack on your house
mm-hmm
shut off everything you're in a dark but
you have chili mac with beef what's the
hacker gonna do then exactly I've been
prepared for all of those oh you have
except a terrorist attack I know what to
do in every situation aside from a
terrorist attack that was never on my
apocalypse checklist
emergency kids should be stored in
airtight plastic bags and put into easy
to carry containers like a duffel bag I
was hoping for I was hoping for
you guys bringing us here and showing us
things that we could eat to make me feel
like leaving here I could be more
prepared but I just feel more in danger
you don't know anything we're not
prepared for a disaster that's why we're
in this video basic necessities for an
emergency supply kit include water at
least one gallon of water per person and
each pet food at least a three day
supply of non-perishable food
battery-powered hand-cranked radio as
well as a NOAA Weather Radio of tone
alert flashlight your phone doesn't
count
get a real flashlight first-aid kit a
whistle to signal for help
dust masks plastic sheeting and duct
tape moist towels garbage bags and
plastic ties this is a lot of stuff that
wrench or pliers manual can opener local
maps who uses local maps a more you
better get you what you think you're
gonna have a GPS in the afterlife no
cell phone with chargers and a backup
battery if you have a pet pet food and
extra water for your bath that's a lot
that's a lot okay here's also my mindset
right you want me to have all of that
and an extra pair of clothes like I'm
supposed to carry all this to where if I
kept this in my pantry I would imagine I
might crack it open on a day that I
didn't go through the dropping I will
keep these in my house I don't think
they'd make it to the disaster prep
because they're pretty good and have my
grocery low I probably eat it which
means I wouldn't have anything left for
disaster so I would eat this right right
if you were to put that on a plate him
in like here I'm like okay if I had a
lot of this I would be very lenient as
to what I would call a disaster yeah
I've I gots a rainy day
yeah time to crack it yeah good a
dimension the only problem I have is
that this expires pretty soon it expires
in 2048 so I don't know if this has a
place in
okay so would you buy this one and what
are your thoughts I would buy this one
over this one for the simple fact I know
I will not open this whoa yeah I bought
a service purpose it will last me
through the disaster and I can ration it
because I want one yeah I feel like I
learned a lot of stuff that I already
knew but it kind of reinforced things
there like you need to be prepared you
really never know when things are gonna
go down the producer is reading us
asking us if you think these are smart
to be prepared for yes we know this is
what you're supposed to prepare for yeah
it is a good idea to have these things
it is
[Music]